it's as a dream destination for many who
come to Russia here I'm closer to
America than to Europe surrounded by the
sea marked by volcanoes Kamchatka the
end of the world
it's an ideal place for adventurers
formerly a restricted military zone than
abdicates long sleeping beauty Kamchatka
is livelier today than ever before
Kamchatka sounds like a dream beautiful
nature romantic mountains is the ocean
but real life as so often looks far
different from that beauty I experienced
this reality on the western side of the
peninsula at the Sea of Okhotsk in
October ski a fishing village of one and
a half thousand residents during the
Soviet period up to six thousand people
lived here they worked in state and
fisheries most of them have long since
closed since then October ski has been a
playground for anyone who wants to earn
money from fishing especially fishing
wild salmon a quarter of all North
Pacific wild salmon comes from Kamchatka
these temporary fishing huts pop up
every couple of hundred meters as they
have replaced the large factories this
man owns one of them Andre he doesn't
want to reveal his surname I'm now
building three new rules for my
colleagues over there with a dining room
and a TV
his colleagues are about a dozen koryaks
and Ethel manse members of the
Aboriginal ethnic groups of kamchatka
Anthony is one of the few who is willing
to talk to me after all the subject is
fish and fish means man in Kamchatka
lots of money and where there is a lot
of money the rules for earning its are
interpreted to one's own advantage those
fish over there take them what Andrea
and his men are doing is actually
illegal fishing with Nets but the
fisherman complains that the rules are
so contradictory and complicated that he
would rather rely on his own wisdom
the sea is my teacher like a hunter it
teaches me when and where I can catch
the creatures that's my philosophy of
life so if you love the indigenous
people need to work which is why they
have more rights as fishermen event the
Russians exceptions are made for koryaks
and Italians take the one in the middle
yes that one's okay
they are allowed to fish with nets since
it's part of their traditional way of
life but there are exceptions to the
exemptions especially valuable fish must
be thrown back into the sea this upsets
and a congestus wishes to it vanna order
in Kamchatka there are two indigenous
groups
it's ailments in Korea they have special
status with the officials who make the
rules here don't even want to look at
the history Poznan is blue the term
valuable fish may exist in industrial
fishing but not in the lives of the
indigenous people the more one is really
they simply know fish and fish for them
means liable but the most HD machine
of the authorities tend to be more
generous or when more generous sums of
money are paid so that's something I
witness when my short trip to ball Shire
a car in the bay of the Sea of Okhotsk
here I meet tourists who pay a lot of
money for a fishing license for wild
salmon even when the Chaves are the
highly sought after chinook salmon
returns to its birthplace in the stream
to spawn ideally of course we catch the
young mothers female fish but the day
there's just a young male so no caviar
otherwise we need the caviar first and
then the meat the fish itself fishing
for wild salmon is supposed to attract
tourists to Kamchatka at the moment only
if you have come a blessing for the
peninsula's nearly untouched nature